this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by curiosity stream watch
over 2400 documentaries for free for 31
days at curiosity stream comm Ford /
real engineering we've all been there
visiting your local hardware store like
a kid in a candy shop you arrive at the
pick-and-mix crew section and you were
just overcome with excitement how could
you possibly pick just one screw Wow
look at all these screws amazing you
have sultry slotted screws playful
Phillips oh and look at this one a hex
screw you naughty polygon in your
excitement you picked the largest bag
you can find and fulfill your childhood
dreams to buy two of every kind of screw
mother can't stop you now you arrived
home with the glee of a spring lamb oh
the assembly that awaits
what joy then to your horror you open
your toolbox to discover you only have a
flat flathead screwdriver that doesn't
even fit the flathead screws you bought
your life is the lie you spent your life
studying theory I never learned
practical application you are no real
engineer Shh it's all going to be okay
try those existential crisis tears we
are going to learn what all these screws
are for and how they came into existence
the humble screw is a technology so old
that we cannot easily determine who
first invented it but the answer as best
we can tell is Archimedes who used the
helical screws ability to turn
rotational motion into linear force to
pump water though he probably stole the
idea from the Egyptians you can imagine
how a screw works fairly simply by
viewing the cross-section at the bottom
this part is essentially a wedge and
when you force a wedge under something
it will lift it up this wedge shape
spirals all the way up the screw
allowing that force to be applied along
the full length of the screw this idea
was used for centuries to pump water dig
holes and for pressing the [ __ ] out of
grapes to make some wine then some
unknown person had a bright idea if we
can apply an opposing force we could
create compression to hold two parts
together and so someone slapped a head
on one of these screws that would press
down while the threads pulled upwards
creating an incredibly useful fastener
this idea didn't
eally take off until a method of mass
manufacturing them came about in 1797
when henry Maudsley invented this metal
cutting lathe that allowed for the
consistent and precise cutting of screw
threads he even set up a standard screw
thread geometry for his machine shop and
cut all his nuts and bolts to fit those
threads and thus the chaos started
several decades of differing standards
resulted in headaches far worse than
your annoyance at your new phone not
fitting your old charging dock perhaps
the most notable incompatibility
occurred during the great boston fire of
1872 when fire departments from
neighboring regions arrived to help only
to discover their fire hoses didn't fit
Boston's fire hydrants most of the world
has now accepted isometric threads as a
standard although one country is still
holding on to the inch as the standard
unit of measurement a measurement that
was legally defined as the length of
three grains of barley drying round
placed end to end lengthwise for eight
centuries until it was redefined as
twenty five point four millimeters
because as we all know the best in class
is always defined by the second best but
I digress
we can now generally trust that a nut
and bolt with the same diameter will fit
even when mixing freedom units and
metric but what's the story with all
these different screw heads why can't we
just agree on one shape so we don't need
a toolbox full of screwdrivers the
simple slotted screw head was likely the
first type used as it's easy and cheap
to manufacture with a cutting tool but
is a pretty terrible design for anything
other than manual screw driving into
wood screwdrivers can slip out of the
sides and you can turn the screw off its
center axis which causes it to drive
into the material at an angle this was
not acceptable for mass production
methods which as we explored previously
needed a foolproof production method so
Peter Lim Berner Robertson designed a
manufacturing process for this square
bit screw head which was designed to be
easily and quickly driven home without
danger of the screw driver slipping out
and damaging either the screw or the
workpiece 700 of these bad boys were
used in the model
and it saved Henry Ford about two hours
of manufacturing time on each and every
vehicle Henry Ford was so happy with the
design that he wanted to license it and
manufacture them himself to ensure he
had a reliable and steady supply of the
fastener but Robertson wasn't about that
money-making life and said no he
continued doing this with other
manufacturers for some bizarre reason
and now the design is mostly just used
in Canada and so in stepped Henry F
Phillips with his infuriating screw
design he license out the design to
Henry Ford and many other people this
conical cross design allowed for a
single screwdriver to fit many sizes of
screws was self centering and was
designed to cause the screwdriver to
slip out of the slot at a certain torque
and thus prevent workers from over
tightening it and damaged a screwdriver
or workpiece it also prevents you from
getting the blasted thing out of a
workpiece with even the slightest bit of
rust by 1939 this design was licensed to
nearly every automotive airplane and
rail manufacturer in the US just in time
for the boom in manufacturing created by
World War two with the lend-lease act
many American designs were sold to their
allies and thus the screw design spread
even further now that most screwdrivers
can automatically limit torque the
Phillips design is pretty much just a
pain in the ass
so other designs have come to the fore
in more recent years specifically
designed to stop that slipping out
called Chemosh like hex screws and
torque screws let's compare these two
types of screw to see how their design
came into existence these two screws
have the same diameter tool both have
six points of contact between the screw
and the tool however we can see when we
rotate our hex tool it contacts the
screw at a greater radius allowing it to
apply more torque with the same force
but the plane of contact is not
perpendicular to the screw and that
means some of the force from the
rotation of the screwdriver is applied
outwards readily to the screw this can
damage both tools with the torque screw
head the angle of contact is near
perpendicular meaning it can apply more
torque without fear of damaging the
screw but ironically even though this is
a great
screw-head design it was designed to not
be used by the general populace it was
used in Apple's first personal computer
to make it harder for the average guy
with a Phillips head screwdriver from
opening up the machine but thanks to its
design Torx screw started proliferating
and more and more people had the correct
tool to loosen it so someone decided to
place a pin in the middle of it to make
it even harder bringing us to an age
where our right to repair is questioned
and many random screw designs have
appeared to make it harder for us to
take apart our gadgets why because whew
that's why if all these nuts are driving
you crazy you might just be a squirrel
and being a worldly squirrel you
probably want to learn about all the
other types of squirrels around the
world
there's one's wings ones with cute
little ears and Tails look at this
ginger one class if you want to learn
more about them I highly recommend
watching this documentary titled going
nuts on curiosity stream it's a
beautifully shot documentary that I've
really enjoyed for a slightly more on
brand recommendation they also have an
exclusive original documentary series
premiering on the 13th of June about the
new race to the moon called return to
the moon
you can watch them for free by signing
up to curiosity stream using the code
real engineering or using the link in
the description this will give you a
month of completely free access to over
2,400 documentaries and nonfiction
titles from some of the world's best
filmmakers after that first free month
you can continue your access for just
$2.99 supporters if you'd like to see
more from me the links to my Instagram
Twitter discord server and subreddit
Ereb below
[Music]
you